there can't be just an infinite number
of explanations for the world because
there's only so many that worked and and
most of them don't
[Music]
work should we give up on a single true
account and accept that there are many
alternative scientific accounts of the
world so this is an interesting uh edgy
version of a debate we're having here
that is a perennial debate that goes
back 100 if not thousands of years in
History of Thought uh philosophers have
argued for since Plato went on about
whether things in the world whether we
can grasp reality or whether it's really
our ideas realism versus
idealism that lies at the core of how
this debate has been formulated now I'd
like to disagree a bit with the premise
of the debate to begin with because I
believe that when you study science uh
and how science has developed and
particularly in the 20th century and the
century There Is Ours
science is not fundamentally driven by a
Quest For Truth which is usually the
premise for most of these debate uh when
you look at it more closely science is
fundamentally driven by what you can do
with it with action with mobilization
with putting something into use truth is
almost like a secondary effect or maybe
in the minds of many individual
scientists this is what they're looking
for but the Endeavor of science moves in
a somewhat different direction so to
give you an example from particle
physics for example has in the last
century been able to and especially in
the last 50 years developed a very very
sophisticated model for uh the subatomic
particles that has been uh repeatedly
shown to be consistent and is gathered
as a very consistent valid model
now uh virtual particles quasi particles
subatomic particles we see them as
integers on a screen that's how the
physicist would see them experimentally
and of course philosophers could turn to
say is that reality that we're capturing
on the screen or is that really just an
a correlation that is just a reflection
of something that is not ultimately
reality now from the scientific
perspective uh this debate is very
academic because it doesn't really
matter if it's real or not what matters
is what you can do with it so as soon as
you discover something like a subatomic
particle it doesn't really matter to the
scientist whether that is ultimately
true or not it matters how you can
mobilize it what you can do with it and
so uh I think this is important to keep
in mind when we talk about science uh
that not primarily like we like to think
that it's ultimately about finding the
truth of the universe but we should
perhaps pay more attention to what the
purpose of that science is like what how
we are using the science thank you very
much Michael yeah I think that's I think
that's right um the application of
knowledge to solving problems is
probably the key to science's success So
to that extent there can't be just an
infinite number of explanations for the
world because there's only so many that
worked and and most of them don't work
and uh so I guess if we encountered
extraterrestrial
intelligences you know are they
using
spacecraft propulsion systems that are
like ours they won't C it Newtonian
gravity because they won't have a Newton
they'll call it whatever
their zenu the galactic Warrior physics
or whatever Scientology reference anyway
uh uh but you know they won't call it
from O's Last Theorem but they'll have
something like that that's our
presumption assum assuming gravity works
on other planets or galaxies or whatever
it's it's probably true so that's not
culturally relative it if it turns out
they have a completely different physics
well that would be interesting but even
here here you know there's not Indian
physics and British physics and American
well there's different interests but you
know it's just the same physics unlike
religion you know which is definitely
culturally bound right and then even in
social science problems like why is
there inflation and how do we control
inflation well you have economists that
are sort of right leaning economists
that are left leaning kenian economists
or whatever but there's not like a
hundred different theories there's maybe
two or three and we nudge them this way
or that way so I think it's limited
based not just on our cognition or the
size of our brains or how they're
structured but also the world itself is
limited and so you you can only have so
many explanations that actually work to
do something and therefore I would not
agree that you know it's all culturally
bound and there's just an infinite
number of explanations thank you chetra
okay I'm going to you ask me to disagree
and I'm going to disagree so um the way
I see it and this applies across the
sciences and the the Arts and everything
is that we um I am not an idealist so I
do believe there is an objective reality
and the fundamental problem which
actually beond has already um mentioned
is that we are only able to perceive or
even attempt to perceive that objective
reality through our senses so we are
limited at the base by these our senses
and indeed Heisenberg famously showed
that the senses not only limit what we
can OB observe but also intervene so as
soon as we try to observe it it changes
this reality so so nonetheless you know
we can see a fish we can touch it we can
smell it and therefore we have a
representation or the phenomena of of
fish available to us through our senses
but as we've always wanted to know more
we want to understand sort of what is a
fish what's the essence of fish we're
always trying to head towards that's our
fundamental human Quest um the will as
shophow would call it where we try and
understand this subjective reality uh we
try and go beyond what our senses can
tell us by replacing it with an
abstraction and in science that's
typically a model so a model so this
sort of desire to understand the
objective reality has to be mediated
through building models but what's very
important is a model is an abstraction
it's it's not a replica so when we talk
about realism and is a model you know is
it right is it correct I think we are
misinterpreting the whole process so
George box the statistician famously
said all models are wrong but some are
useful I really find that quote
extremely irritating because models are
not supposed to be right and actually
here I suppose I'm not really
disagreeing because precisely what you
said beyond and um you know it's not
really about does this model is it a
replica of the reality that we're trying
to find out it's more a question of does
this model which is always going to be
wrong there is no way a model can be
right but does it give you an insight
into the system what what is it about
the model then that provides an a better
understanding of the system so I'm going
to just toss out a quote that I often do
when I'm talking about models and
realism
and what we can expect of a model um I'm
going to end with a quote from Georgia
o'keef where she says nothing is less
real than realism details are confusing
it's only by selection by elimination by
emphasis that we get at the real meaning
of things but I do think that the reason
why we have models is yes of course to
use them to send us to the moon and
whatnot but it's really really out of a
more fundamental will to try and
understand that objective reality that
we're fac okay to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I.V
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest
ideas